are you there's a situation that happens
when you become a parent where you make
friends with the other parents that's a
big part of the community I don't know
how it is in the rest of the world but
in Los Angeles like preschool and
kindergarten that's kind of where you
have a second chance to start making
friends with people and it's a it's a
big deal and I find with that because I
work on the same couple shows and have
great guy friends but I'm very always
very hungry for women friends hungry
wasn't the right word but no it's good
it's haven't eaten in six months by the
way all the cheese and crackers you left
in my dressing room so yeah but yeah so
you go and you become friends with these
people and you're all kind of vetting
each other to see who's gonna hang out
with who and there was this one woman
that I just was very attracted to right
away and she was very sweet and she is a
really good mom and she's funny and cute
and so we kind of exchanged numbers and
I find myself texting her and like kind
of rereading it to make sure it's just
funny enough but not courting her and
I'm showing up a little early to pick up
to see if she did my husband and my
other girlfriends are like Oh how's your
girlfriend today girlfriend return your
texts in a way in an appropriate time
and like yoga pants yet you punch well I
think they're gonna definitely need us
to remake anyway I find myself trying to
woo this woman and and it's getting
weird to where now we're kind of weird
around each other so I'm like okay I'm
just gonna have over for dinner we'll
watch bad TV Rob was out of town again
my husband travels a lot yeah so I have
her come over I have the kids by myself
it's Friday night it's pizza and movie
night at our house so I make them food I
turn on the fire which I always
you cuz it's like sets the mood for
going to bed I'm thinking okay I'm gonna
make dinner for us now so that when she
comes we can just enjoy it on the couch
hangout I have our let herself in I take
my kids up to bed by the time I get
downstairs she's in the house and I was
like hi how are you and she's just
standing awkwardly in the middle of my
kitchen she's like hi
I look around night has fallen it's dark
in there all of my candles that are on
timers have come on
the fires going there's like dinner why
it's romantic as yeah that is more
romantic than any scenario I've ever
been in in my life I have never been
more sexually attracted to my house like
it was so horrified you think she was a
little creeped out no I mean we you know
we're together now it's good should be
should be together
you